des ateliers pour se glisser dans la
peau d'un sportif en situation de
handicap pour la quatrième année
consécutive la ville de plaisir organise
au palais des sports ces journées
destinées aux enfants de la commune
scolarisés en primaire et au collège
objectif sensibiliser la nouvelle
génération sur la situation de handicap
qu'ils puissent se projeter un petit peu
sûres
sur les différents types de handicaps
physiques pour le coup qu'on a et qu'on
va représenter sur cette semaine et que
les enfants puissent en parler autour
d'eux par la suite et se rendre compte
de l'importance des difficultés les
personnes handicapées on se mouvoir de
faire des activités mais aussi des
possibilités c'est pas parce que on se
retrouve en situation de handicap qu'on
ne peut plus rien faire
au programme notamment de cette journée
du tennis de table handisport les jeunes
ont pu tester la discipline avec un
bandeau sur les yeux ou sur des chaises
autres activités farid et le basket
fauteuil c'est assez compliqué déjà de
se diriger de faire des dribbles et de
marquer surtout faucon-lambert réussir
parce qu'on est barque on est dans un
fauteuil donc pour tirer faut
s'entraîner on voit que c'est difficile
et qu'ils veulent quand même quand même
le faire au total près de 600 jeunes de
la ville participent à ces journées de
sensibilisation dans le cadre de la
semaine du handicap
une cinquième édition sera programmée
l'année prochaine